there's a wealth of classic fast food
dishes we know and love
from hot dogs and kebabs to tacos and
burgers but the great thing about making
them at home
is you can throw away the rule book and
get creative
my next easy recipe is a miniature
version of an american favorite
the burger smoky pork sliders with
barbecue sauce
everyone loves a burger they're a true
fast food original
and that's the exciting thing about
street food you can take an old classic
like that
and reinvent it into something really
exciting
when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce and a light
smoky barbecue goes hand in glove with a
great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper now the
secret of a good
barbecue sauce is that really important
caramelization
to begin with a nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
it darkens the onions but it really
starts to sort of
give that nice syrupy body to the sauce
and put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices i've got to cook them out
and almost sort of
burn off that rawness especially with a
smoked paprika
that's exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic
beautifully caramelized
cider vinegar in reduce that down
now i've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce i'm making my life
really easy and adding pre-made
worcester sauce
and tomato ketchup cook that out for two
to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce
that determines how long you cook it out
for i don't want it to be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either that's the
consistency we're looking for
lovely turn down the gas
charger seasoning
now take that out it's the kind of sauce
that i like to have sort of
bottled up in the fridge it's great for
sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders homemade
smoky barbecue sauce
[Music]
give the pan a little wipe now start the
mix for the sliders
to give my mix a really interesting
flavor and texture i'm gonna be using
unsmoked back bacon
i travel all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders
and it's almost like a way of having a
burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
a little teaspoon of olive oil i want
that bacon to get really nice and crispy
bacon in this just gives the really nice
sort of
chunky delicious mix i want texture
and pork is perfect for a slider
[Music]
and choppy shallot
slots are a lot sweeter than your normal
white onion
fine fine fine and in
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there
a little teaspoon of smoked paprika in
there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like
four or five of them little mini one
biters
incredible now take your pork
just open it up and give that a really
nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so season it nicely
bacon now that's nice and crispy just
take
a little touch kitchen roll and just
drain that off there
nice pat that nice and dry
i want all that nice sort of crispiness
in there beautiful mix all that
in take a nice ball
and sort of roll it
the size of a golf ball get it nice
and round first and then three fingers
just pat that down don't flatten them
too thin otherwise they overcook and
they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going to take two and a half to
three minutes to each side in
turn them over lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them keep my
mouth watering now
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now your fingers is
nice and firm it's a little touch of
springiness
in the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted
i'm using wedges of smoked cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess
to the slider finally shredded baby gem
lettuce
just take those buns make sure they're
sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce
be quite generous when the lettuce it's
a nice thin slice
of tomato take your burgers
you see that cheese you feed melted
your bbq sauce
place the top on and that is my version
the slider that is small dynamic but
packed
full of flavor i'll take that over a
hamburger any day
here are three effortless recipes that
are ready literally in minutes
first up noodle soup with poached egg
and spring onions
[Music]
add miso paste to boiling water
japanese miso has a wonderful deep
savoury richness and is brilliant in
soups
grating fresh ginger add dry shiitake
mushrooms
that have been soaked in water
season with soy sauce crack an egg
add it to the broth and poach for two to
three minutes
add thinly sliced portobello mushrooms
to a serving bowl
put in fresh medium egg noodles which
will heat through in the hot meso broth
add spinach
then simply spoon the broth into your
bowl
top with the egg and fresh chopped
spring onions
so simple so good and so delicious ready
in 10 minutes
super fast noodle soup with poached egg
and spring onions
my next easy dish using the versatile
noodle is
stir fried pork noodles
first marinade pork mince and shaoxing
rice wine
a fortified chinese wine soy sauce
and sesame oil
next fry chopped ginger in hot olive oil
and garlic
[Music]
next add szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor
and gives a pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince
[Applause]
and brown if you want more seasoning
add extra soy sauce then add fiery chili
bean paste
and rice wine vinegar
[Music]
add in cooked egg noodles
mix together finally
top with chopped spring onion and
toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
packed with flavor and on the table in
15 minutes delicious
stir-fried pork noodles
[Music]
my next noodle dish you can knock up in
no time is
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
[Music]
add chopped onions to hot olive oil
garlic
chilli and fry
grating ginger next lemongrass
first bash it with a knife doing this
will help release its wonderful lemony
flavour
and scent now aromatic kaffir lime
leaves
then ground cumin coriander and turmeric
next add cream coconut chicken stock
fish sauce and simmer
soak rice vermicelli noodles in hot
water
[Applause]
[Music]
drain and add to your serving bowl
pour over the aromatic soup broth
finish with coriander and chopped chili
on the table in around 20 minutes
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
real fast food
fast healthy delicious free
mouthwatering recipes
guaranteed to help you master the art of
incredible tasting noodles